buona sera io faccio ricerca in
astrofisica in pratica studio come è
fatto l'universo
ed è un bel mestiere perché mi dà la
possibilità di guardare pezzi del cielo
si è abbassata perché c'è un pochino le
luci che sono fantastici
questo sembra un quadro in realtà
sembrano delle nubi in cielo pronto
temporale realtà sono è una regione del
cielo di diversi anni luce dove c'è gas
e polvere dove si formano delle stelle
la nebulosa testa di cavallo un'altra
nebuloso molto più piccola al centro c'è
una stellina che sta per morire non lo
fa in maniera molto lenta
prima si libera del materiale che
circonda il nucleo le corse dell'anno
negli anni lascerà il nucleo nudo la
morte di un'altra stella in questo in
questo caso è già avvenuta la morte
attraverso un esplosione
guardate la perfezione di questa
immagine sembra una gigantesca bolla di
sapone che sta viaggiando si sta
espandendo nello spazio alla velocità di
cinquemila chilometri al secondo
fate ricerca scientifica in astrofisica
non è solo ammette guardare belle
immagini si tratta anche di studiare
segnale molto debole che ha viaggiato
tantissimo molto da molto lontano
questo è il caso della legazione cosmica
di fondo che dimostrato la n'attimo la
radiazione cosmica di fondo e qui adesso
ci sarà per sempre nell'universo destata
avuto origine
13 pt 13 miliardi di anni fa quando la
materia e la redazione
hanno rotto il loro perfetto equilibrio
da quel momento in poi la radiazione
iniziata vigliatore quasi liberamente e
ci è giunta oggi in questa forma
i punti sono le misure il picco di
questa radiazione nelle microonde e il
modello teorico pasta e spazza
esattamente attraverso i punti è
l'esempio di accordo tra teoria e misura
sperimentale meglio riuscita nella
storia dell'umanità dove il mondo delle
estremamente piccolo viene spiega
esattamente cosa è successo all'inizio
dei lavori dell'universo è una delle
scoperte più importanti mai fatte dall
umanità e anche una grandissima conferma
che la teoria del big bang è vera per
noi fare ricerca vuol dire semplicemente
muoversi enterite risconosciuti e per
molti questo vuol dire vincere la paura
è quello che ci fa vincere la paura e la
curiosità che la curiosità veramente non
può fermare niente delle volte significa
anche fare delle affermazioni che
possono metterci nei guai un esempio su
tutti galileo galilei che per aver
contestato le idee dell'epoca delle
autorità per aver propagandato il fatto
che non è il sole che si muove intorno
alla terra nella terra che si muove
intorno al sole ha passato gli ultimi
anni della sua vita agli arresti
domiciliari e per me avere coraggio oggi
vuol dire riconoscere che uno dei
problemi fondamentali per noi
e questo numero sette miliardi 188
milioni 350 3.390 non è la tassa che
dovete pagare per la casa e il numero di
abitanti che popolano il pianeta terra
oggi e non è il numero in sé che fa
paura che veramente trovo
insomma spaventoso e il fatto che siamo
arrivati a questo numero in una velocità
impressionante
oggi questa è la storia della crescita
demografica degli ultimi 160 anni 160
anni una popolazione mondiale è
cresciuta di un fattore 10 gli esperti
la chiamano esplosione demografica e non
ha avuto nessun rallentamento non ha
rallentato nemmeno in occasione del
conflitto mondiale più importante della
storia dell'umanità la seconda guerra
mondiale che ha fatto più di 50 milioni
di morti in pochissimo tempo
se andiamo un pochino più in passato la
crescita c'è sempre stata anche se molto
più lenta e per renderci conto da dove
siamo partiti mostro qui la storia degli
ultimi 12 mila anni l'unica volta in cui
c'è stato veramente un rallentamento è
stato nel xiv secolo quando c'è stata la
peste bubbonica che ha veramente
devastato la popolazione mondiale e nel
mondo e in europa in particolare
interessante vedere che nel trend stesso
al quinto secolo avanti cristo
c'è stato qualcuno che ha scritto
crescete e moltiplicatevi
e così è stato nel giro di pochi secoli
quando è nato gesù di nazaret la
popolazione mondiale è triplicata e
all'inizio della rivoluzione neolitica
cioè per 12.000 anni fa la popolazione
mondiale era meno di 5 milioni di
abitanti
in pratica la popolazione della sicilia
oggi
questo vuol dire che abbiamo infestato
il pianeta a spese di tantissime specie
animali e vegetali e questo perché
abbiamo questo forte desiderio di vivere
a lungo per noi stessi per i nostri cari
però forse dobbiamo guardare un pochino
alla nostra vita in un'altra ottica non
vivere in eterno ma vivere bene la
nostra vita lasciare in qualche modo
ricordo motivo per essere ricordati per
per lungo tempo e in questa occasione vi
racconto una grande storia di coraggio
una storia di una persona che ha trovato
il modo per essere ricordata nonostante
sia stata una storia di una persona che
ha perduto in qualche modo era nei
giochi olimpici di atene nel 1896 pierre
de coubertin volle i giochi della i
primi giochi dell'era moderna questa
un'immagine dello stadio per de
coubertin e conosciuto perché disse
questa frase illuminata che non è
importante vincere ma partecipare però
non tutti sanno che lui imposta la
regola puoi partecipare se sei uomo le
donne non erano ammesse in quell'epoca
c'era una donna greca e che vuole fare
la maratona questa è l'immagine della
maratona dei quattro partecipanti dei
diciassette iscritti alla gara
la maratona era la gara più
significativa la donna che si presentò
alla l'iscrizione si chiamava st mata
hari viti all'epoca aveva 30 anni aveva
già avuto due figli l'ultimo un anno e
mezzo si presentò prima della gallup per
la registrazione ufficiale
lei pensava che correndo questa gara
avrebbe migliorato la sua condizione di
povertà però sfortunatamente gli venne
impedito di partecipare ma la cosa bella
la dimostrazione di coraggio che lei non
si diede per vinta la gara la fece lo
stesso
il giorno dopo e si parla di questo
evento nel giornali dell'epoca le corse
impiego o cinque ore e mezza fece 40 km
e l'ultimo giro non lo fece dentro lo
stadio perché le venne impedito di
entrare lo fece fuori dallo stadio
attraverso questa storia
lei ha voluto lasciare un segno in
realtà
non è diventata ricca non ha vinto come
avrebbe desiderato però ha lasciato
memoria di sé nella storia dell'umanità
successiva quindi non ha inventato la
vita eterna però inventato la vita della
sua anima eterna nelle nostre nei nostri
pensieri e del posto pensiero grazie